again welcome everyone we're going to be
starting here in just a few more minutes
and in the meantime uh please take a few
minutes to sign up on
learn.onmexlogic.com
we're going to be going through this
site uh today in our session
and we're going to begin in just a few
more minutes we're going to let everyone
join so please be patient
thank you
[Music]
thank you
all right uh welcome everyone
uh welcome to this session today we're
going to talk about these upcoming
programs for the 2022 fall virtual
training that we are offering together
with the Louisiana biomedical research
Network and we're going to be talking
about the details of the programs uh
what is going to be covered in each one
of them and how you can benefit from
joining participating and completing
these programs in your biomedical
research projects or just if you're
trying to get started with
bioinformatics
so before we begin I would like to ask
Emmanuel
um if she could briefly talk about the
registration process for those at OSU or
brn and then I'll take over from there
so good afternoon everyone so my name is
Emmanuel
Ruiz and I am gonna be the link between
lbrn and omnic logic and so to help you
with registration and any question so
um for all of you that uh I still
haven't really strong
um I will appreciate that if you can do
it with the form that I'm putting on the
shot right now it's a red cap form it's
a way for us to gather all the person
that will so follow the different
courses and that we can
um
has lbrn is a NIH funded program that we
can
just show to the NIH the work that we
are doing and for the
the accounting perspective so uh we
appreciate that you can
um so fill this form please in a way to
confirm your affiliation with all the
album campuses I need that you
give your institutional email and not
your personal email I really appreciate
that and you can after choose one course
that you want to follow
uh yeah that will be uh important and um
you can after follow the all the
the steps that uh
Mr brewski will Elia will um show you to
go to omnic logic and follow the courses
but this first step is important for the
administ to achieve part of this program
thank you very much
all right great thank you very much
Emmanuel and again welcome everyone I
will also paste in the chat some
information about each one of the
programs with a link and this link as
you will notice is on the Onyx logic
portal so hopefully you have had the
chance to sign up and create an account
but let's first start with this brief
overview we're going to have three
different programs uh they're gonna
start either this week or the next week
if you're not sure which one I hope to
answer all of the questions that you
might have today and we're going to be
looking at what topics are going to be
covered how the programs are organized
what kind of resources you have and
hopefully as you have your questions you
can actually post them in the chat and I
will try to get to them towards the end
of the session
so first of all what is omic's logic uh
how are we connected to the Louisiana
biomedical research Network and how are
we working with the National Association
like video principal investigators that
brings together 23 States in Puerto Rico
Pine biotech the company behind
onyxlogic has been working with the
tower bioinformatics Research Center for
a number of years to develop easy to use
bioinformatics and data science tools
for anyone that is interested in
biomedical research and wants to get
started to use biomedical research
bioinformatics or data science to get
started and so as a result we have been
working with the Louisiana biomedical
research Network for three years now as
well as with other universities around
the country and internationally as well
and we've had over 20 000 students
complete this training with success at
the undergraduate graduate or even
postgraduate levels
now in this year in 2022 we started
working with the National Association of
idea principal investigators and we've
had two pilot programs for faculty and
students uh here's just a few of them
that have recently completed uh the
training that we had over the summer and
the training over the summer was
specifically designed to help introduce
some of the topics like data science
genomics metagenomics and bioinformatics
for infectious diseases and I hope that
today we're going to go through these
new programs that we're going to have in
the next few months to build upon some
of the success of these previous Pilots
what is Onyx logic Onyx Logics is a
collection
is a collection of sorry
six basic topics that were requested uh
okay
um
can you hear me fine Emmanuel yeah okay
somebody mentioned that you cannot hear
me
I can't hear you yes no problem okay
um sorry so um we are going we cover six
basic topics and these topics include
the introduction and overview of
bioinformatics in their application to
different types of automatics data
specific training on genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and an overview of data science and this
is the base curriculum that we
coordinated with researchers and the
directors of the bioinformatics corps at
the Louisiana biomedical research
Network and so made those available both
as a synchronous and uh synchronous
training uh through the Onyx logic
portal
foreign
now in addition to that we want to make
sure that bioinformatics and data
science are consumed in the context of
specialization tracks that we have in
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and Agriculture and so as
you will see these practical skills and
topics are supplemented by projects or
case studies specific to these different
areas of research
one of the priorities that we had from
the beginning was to make sure that
anyone with or without coding skills and
Engineering or technical background can
participate and so a major part of this
coursework is the logic behind these
different types of analysis that are
expanded upon by coding exercises in R
and python so as we get started we're
going to start from the logic of the
analysis why are we doing what we're
doing what are the basic steps and then
if you are interested to learn more in
terms of coding each step can also be
replicated in one of those languages and
the curriculum then goes on to expand
upon those technical skills with
application to different research
studies that are based on Publications
and publicly available data sets
so as we begin let's make sure that
everyone is registered uh here again I
will paste the link
it is learn that omnic logic
.com
and let me
um close my presentation
so we can go through this together
so on this portal I'm already signed in
so I'm going to log out
um when you click on login you will see
that you can create an account
right here
um and you can use one of your social
media accounts but we would ask that you
use your institutional email address so
that we can have a record and an
association with the program that you
are from so what I will do is I will log
in and please do this alongside with me
so that we can go on to the other pages
okay
um which will require that login
information
once you log in you will see this these
are just general resources that you can
search through but what's important is
you will see right here your profile
so here will be your email address mine
is eliad pine.bio and here you will see
your profile so you can click right here
and you will find that this is your
personal profile so what's important at
the beginning of this program is to
complete this program so you can see
right here I have my profile completion
to 100 so that's kind of what we um
asked that you do uh of course having
your full name properly spelled uh
having your social media or your work ID
account connected and having some
description so here you can actually add
information about your current research
maybe what you're interested in or what
program you're from and you can edit
that information by clicking on this
profile button
thank you
Okay so
I will give it just a few minutes
if you could let me know in the chat
that you have completed your profile
so I know to continue
all right thank you Diane
foreign
thank you
all right perfect thank you everyone
so um let's go on then
um after we sign up uh as I mentioned
you will complete your profile and
that's where you will start seeing uh
some important information about your
progress so in fact this is how we are
going to be able to track
um that you are completing the necessary
steps
um that are included in the program
foreign
thank you Michael
so what you will find is that there are
several tabs under your profile and the
first app is activity the second one is
courses programs and then certificates
so what I will be talking today about is
programs that you can choose between and
then within each program courses are
going to be assigned to that program and
as a result of completing the necessary
coursework and attending some of the
sessions that we have planned you will
obtain a certificate for each one of the
courses that are included as well as for
the food program
so at the end you will have a
certificate of completion again for each
individual course and after you complete
all of the steps of the programs that
you are in and that
um with the necessary
um participation and activities you will
get the overall certificate of
completion as well so
um as you navigate the portal you will
find that it is organized according to
different
um kind of ways to navigate this site
and so some people find this a little
bit confusing but that's just because
there's quite a number of options here
so the first option is just to search
for a particular topic so if you go to
the very top of the menu you will find
that there are courses you click there
and you will have some recommended
courses if you're just getting started
or you can search for a topic like
cancer or
uh maybe SARS Cove 2 or something like
that
in addition to that they're going to be
tags on this top right corner where you
can find them organized by whether it's
a project which is like a case study
based on a publication a specific type
uh of a topic like a transcriptomics or
maybe a coding language like r or python
down at the bottom you will also see
some predefined collections of courses
that are organized by these major topics
that we cover on this portal
what I will start with is a collection
called getting started and this
collection is useful for anyone who is
just getting started with bioinformatics
and would like to understand the
terminology and kind of key Concepts
that are important to know as you're
starting to uh use bioinformatics in
your research
so
um as you go along
you will see that there is a point
system that is based on different
activities on the portal so in fact let
me quickly show you if we go back to the
portal
um and instead of courses here at the
end I'm going to go to achievements
and here we can see that all of you for
example have signed up
and you got 50 points for signing up
um and then you can see some other
people that signed up before you and
what happens as you achieve different
Milestones complete the course maybe
complete an exercise things like that
yeah
so as I mentioned after we go through
the basic topics uh you're then
introduced to project examples and these
project examples are case studies that
are designed to illustrate how the
different methods of analysis are
applied in research studies and are
broken down by several different steps
as you go through the different topics
that we will go over in the programs
you're welcome to modify and kind of
choose and pick some projects or case
studies that are more relevant to your
research interests
the overall programs are designed to
combine live sessions like we're having
today with self-guided materials which
we just saw on the portal and practical
assignments that could either be no code
assignments on the T by info platform
which well which I will demonstrate in a
few minutes or assignments in coding
using r or python on the platform with
predefined answers
so
um let's talk a little bit about the
program resources
um so as I mentioned
one of the
um kind of ways that we have designed
these programs is to offer you a
flexible schedule so you can participate
in these live sessions that are
scheduled or some of them will be
asynchronous meaning that you will be
provided with a recorded version that
you can watch at your own time or if you
do join a live session these sessions
are going to allow you to ask questions
you know work with the mentor to
overcome some technical challenges and
the important thing would be to really
follow the structure of these different
programs
that we have explained on each one of
the program pages
so um in the chat I shared some of those
links and then I'm going to put that
again in here
there are three major programs
the first one is Introduction to
bioinformatics
so introduction to bioinformatics is
designed to give you a high level
overview
of genomic transcriptomic and
metagenomic data analysis you can see
that it starts tomorrow
and as you scroll through you will also
see the schedule and what topics are
being covered in that particular program
uh you will also find links under each
session for the specific resource that
is associated with that lecture and you
can complete those resources on your own
now here below you will find some
information about pricing again those of
you that are a part of the Louisiana
biomedical research Network
you have to sign up through the link
that Emmanuel provided and that way if
you qualify your fees are going to be
covered by the Louisiana Environmental
Research Network for those of you that
are not from lbrn or LSU the vet school
there are some discounts available
through the National Association of idea
principal investigators starting with 70
percent
off uh for
um qualifying institutions
now at the bottom of this page you will
also find a list of associated resources
and so for the overview let's just go to
this course bytes and molecules
so the biotin molecules course is
designed to introduce the very Basics
that you have to know to be able to
start with the more advanced courses and
provides a good overview of key topics
that we think are important for anyone
who's starting to work with Onyx data
and that includes general concepts about
genes
um you know the genome uh the code of
life and how it's organized in the DNA
RNA and protein and then a brief
introduction to each one of these topics
like genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics including if you click here
on load more
some applications of bioinformatics in
Precision medicine even space omics and
an introduction to coding so
introduction to bioinformatics languages
like r
in addition to that if we go back to the
program page
you can find at the very bottom
that the expectation is to complete 10
sessions
and once you complete those sessions and
Associated resources you will
automatically see your certificate
appear right here on the side with your
name
so as I mentioned for each one of these
programs you will be granted access to a
number of different resources so first
of all you will notice that in the
portal after you've just signed up you
have a basic account and once you sign
up into one of the programs you will be
given access to a more advanced
subscription that gives you access to
all of the premium coursework that you
will need to complete the program as
well as to the T bioinfo platform
so let me show you what this platform is
and I'll briefly explain how we are
going to use it in the program itself
so you're also welcome to take a look
we're going to paste the link in the
chat
so
um the way that we're going to be using
this platform is by
trying out
some of the analysis methods and making
sure that the analysis logic is well
explained and understood
so let's take a look here at this
example with bulk RNA chic
for Bunker and Asic and in the program
itself you will have some exercises that
you can do independently or in a class
and learn about each step of data
processing analysis and visualization
without uploading any data sets simply
by following some steps that are
predefined on the portal
you will be guided to take the next step
and after you complete the pipeline some
outputs that are explored either on your
computer so downloadable tables
um or visual outputs are going to be
provided as well
in addition to that
you will have some interactive
dashboards that you can use to explore
the data that is produced by that
pipeline so here for example we have
some differential expression uh and and
we can find what are the differentially
expressed genes you see a heat map of
some differentially expressed genes or
even find some specific genes that we
might be interested in and understand
how does the expression of that Gene
vary across different samples that we
had in the bubble pipeline
excuse me
so once um we kind of understand the
logic of this analysis The Next Step
would be to understand how can we
reproduce some of this analysis on our
own
and for that we're going to be working
with tables so you can see that the data
sets are going to be provided right here
and you can download the data for each
type of analysis that we're going to be
working and again as I mentioned for the
introduction to bioinformatics programs
it's going to be focused on genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and a brief
introduction to coding or getting
started with Coatings in R and python
it's
the second program is called data
science for biomedical research
so again all of these links are in the
chat so you can explore this together
with me and this program is more focused
on data visualization statistical
analysis and machine learning in our
sand python
each one of the programs comes with a
short video that gives you an overview
of the topics that are being covered or
you can explore these topics Down Below
on the schedule page and find some
Associated resources that are covered in
that particular session
as I mentioned
the pricing is going to stay the same
and then down below you will find some
additional
kind of expanded coursework
um specific to data science so how to
load your data Wrangle your data and how
to get started with uh statistical
analysis as well as
machine learning so let's take a look at
an example so I'm going to go to this
course
and I'll just face the link in the chat
as well
and let's take a look at this first
lesson
on how to load data and get started in
an R
so I'm hoping that most of you are
familiar with what R is
um R is a language that is often used in
bioinformatics and there are many useful
packages for data visualization and so
what we'll do here is is we'll first go
over the syntax of the code so we'll
understand how code is organized
and then once we understand how it is
organized we can also try to run one of
these exercises on our own to understand
how it works so I'm going to go to this
section called try yourself
so what happens here is each one of
these code blocks could be run
and then you can see that there are some
instructions that I have to follow for
this code to actually work and right
here I will have some outputs that can
give me an idea of what I'm doing wrong
and how I can fix this code
you can see that the instructions are to
import and view a text file so I can use
the text file link
replace this right here
run it
and find another problem
okay you can see that again
I have a problem
and so to understand what I should do
I can go back
and I can see how this code is actually
organized and what I should do to be
able to fix the error so let's go back
okay read table
foreign
and success so what these exercises
teach us is that it's very important to
follow directions understand what the
code does be able to read the code
identifying mistakes and then when we
are successful at reproducing what the
exercise is expecting from us we're
going to get points so what I can do now
is go to the next one
and again see what I need to change here
based on the previous assignment and try
to fix all of them up until I get to
more and more advanced types of
assignments like writing functions uh
and and Performing more and more complex
analyzes that are going to be very
useful if you're going to be working
with omics data so again you can see
some of the examples
um down below so these are some of the
things that we're going to be doing in
this course of course we're also going
to be working with python in Python you
will also get challenges that you can
save eventually as a project of your own
using jupyter notebooks add them to your
GitHub profile and start developing a
portfolio of uh kind of coding exercises
that you have completed and maybe even
turn them into projects
the final uh program that I want to
briefly discuss today is called
bioinformatics and biomedical research
so the way this program is different
from the previous two is that it is
really more focused on solving real
challenges with data analysis in
application to real projects so instead
of focusing on kind of skill development
we're going to go through several case
studies where you will be able to
appreciate how different approaches in
data processing data analysis data
visualization machine learning and
statistical analysis could be very
useful to study these Topics in
Precision medicine or biomedical
research
so what the goal of this program is
again to give you some overview of the
basic methods and then introduce you to
some of these case studies where these
methods are used and compare how we can
perform similar analysis uh using data
from the public domain and so there is
going to be a lesson that is going to be
dedicated to finding
um and using some of these public domain
repositories where the data could be
used to generate a hypothesis practice
and replicate similar results to what
the authors found but importantly to
connect the insights from data analysis
with our ability to interpret them for
biomedical research purposes
so the way that these programs are
organized is by level
uh you can see that uh we kind of have a
beginner level and that beginner level
is the introduction to bioinformatics
we have an intermediate level which is
skill oriented and this is specifically
for those who want to either get started
with coding or would like to improve
their coding skills and then finally we
have a more research oriented program
that is going to provide less technical
kind of training and more focused on how
to integrate the understanding of
biology with these insights from the
data analysis process
so at this moment I want to pause and
just ask if anyone has any questions
about these programs
about these programs about how to sign
up about what maybe a program is the
right one for you
um or about anything else that we've
covered so far
foreign
a little bit clearer
um so the introduction to bioinformatics
that say I want to select that one is
the pricing uh 150 300 450
for
for that one program or does that cover
all three if you if you do the 90 days I
I don't really understand the pricing is
for each of these three or for all three
yeah so and and Diane where uh which
university are you from Boise State or
an idea state so through Navy okay
yeah so so then you know don't sign up
for it right now if you're from one of
those programs
um you just have to fill out the form
and say that you're interested in that
program and then someone will send you a
registration link with a discount so
your pricing is going to be like 70 off
so could I start tomorrow even though I
haven't had got that pricing yet
yes yes tomorrow so the uh the first
session in each one of these programs is
free for anyone anyone can join to just
kind of understand how it works
um and then you know once you say yes
this is what I wanted to do then we'll
send you that discount link now I do
want to mention about one versus two
versus three programs uh what we found
is that people who sign up for three
typically don't complete any of them and
one of our objectives here is to help
um you know people participants to
complete at least one that's a metric
that helps us demonstrate that these
programs could be completed that we
should continue to improve them and work
with these universities to kind of
establish common format for them to
participate so I would recommend
choosing one
um if you don't know which one is best
for you you know maybe joining the first
session in each one could be a good
strategy to kind of understanding how
they differ and then you know make
making a choice about just one
and so if I do the first one and decide
to do the second one will it start like
a week after or immediately after next
semester or something will they go in
order once I start or are they broken up
by some other way
yeah they're going to be on different
days okay they're all going to be
starting in October and Lasting until
the end of December
um again
um sorry just one second
um sorry about that yeah so what I was
saying is that um you know you um uh the
the different days are going to be uh
for different programs uh and then you
know if you
um not all of these sessions are going
to be live so it's not like it's going
to last you know all of these months so
if you come complete one and then you
decide you want to switch to another one
it will be just a different day during
the week where that session would be and
different set of resources that you will
have access to
fantastic thank you
all right thank you Matthew basically if
you don't know if you qualify if you are
from any of the institutions that are in
the nepi network you most likely qualify
if you submitted a form we're going to
review the form submissions uh by uh
next week when all of these first
sessions are going to be over and we're
going to get back to you
and um Rajesh
if you're trying to choose introduction
to bioinformatics and you don't see an
option to choose
basically I think following the links
that I shared
um you know are you able to access those
links those links are
um after you sign up you should be able
to see them
okay
um so the form was sent out by email and
Matthew could I just ask you which
university you're from
I'm from Delaware State University
okay yeah so you do qualify
um if you signed up with your Delaware
State email address uh then you should
be getting an email
um in the next few days about completing
that registration
okay thank you
yeah sure
all right so great questions again
Rajesh if you want to
um also if you have any additional
questions after this session you can
always email me
um Amelia Pine dot bio that's for people
that are not from LSU and lbrn if you
are from LSU or lbrn I suggest
contacting Emmanuel
um Emmanuel maybe you could share your
email address there as well
foreign
yes okay perfect thank you Manuel
um so um yes ULM uh is a part of the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
so please do reach out to Emmanuel if
you haven't already filled out the form
which we also shared in the beginning
maybe we could share that again
so this form
is for anyone who's from the Louisiana
biomedical research Network
and what you should do is you should
fill out the form and then follow
instructions maybe manual you could
repeat what the instructions are for
those who are from Louisiana yeah so uh
some of the people are from Louisiana
so if you still haven't done it so you
can fill the form on Red Cap
um so we just ask that you put your name
email address particularly your
institutional email it is important
because it's in this way that we confirm
your affiliation to the different
confuses that belong to lbrn and after
you just have to
um
but which program you would like to
follow and uh that's it we don't have
much we don't ask a lot of information
all right perfect so again filling out
the form is kind of the The Next Step
um I saw another question
um
uh for about discount so yes if you are
a part of lbrn the programs are going to
be free for you
um and then uh and that will be through
your institution but as a part of lbr
rent
okay
so
um hopefully we were able to answer a
lot of the questions
um in today's session we had a much more
um in-depth uh review of the program
topics in our previous session and we're
going to follow up with a video
recording of that um overview
uh the deadline for completing the
program uh Matthew is December 31st
um and the deadline for registration is
by the end of next week so we will have
a free session anyone can join tomorrow
so we'll have a free session on Friday
so these are again going to be according
to the different programs and then next
week on the 26th
um yes uh ashik you have a question
yes I have a question actually uh during
the registration in Red Cap while I am
giving my email address of uh my um
address is saying that email must be an
Institutional email address to be
accepted yeah but I don't know why I am
putting my initiation traditional email
address in full but it's showing me this
it's not acceptable I think I think you
know why ULM has two um types of email
addresses right yes yeah for example
um
I think you already have uh registered
so you it may be if it's not accepted
it's because you already have done it so
you are already on a files
okay okay I think so I think is that
uh it's the same for for Russia's Russia
is actually I hope I say it well uh yeah
you cannot you already have registered
so if you give your same email address
or your institution or email you already
have on his file so uh
sorry it's not gonna accept it one more
one more time
how can I access to my account then can
you please say it again
to your account yes which I mean uh how
can I how can I uh as I think I
restarted from uh in the last uh summer
and I didn't able to complete full of
the clinic but I want to complete it now
so can you please tell me how can I uh
access this uh
the training model
yeah I think what will happen is you
know as Emmanuel said your registration
on Red Cap is complete and now once that
list is approved uh so I think Dr
Casillas will have to approve the list
and then once those names are approved
you will receive an email
um on getting into the sessions and uh
you know that's how you know that you've
been accepted and you will be able to
complete these programs
okay thank you
foreign great so again hopefully
um and for Matthew I posted in the chat
so we will be emailing again there's
kind of a registration process where we
validate that you're from the right
institution uh that falls under the
correct category
and then once that is approved we'll be
able to send you all of the information
but regardless of the information about
all of the sessions you will receive an
invitation for the sessions in the next
few days to join the first orientation
session about each one of these programs
introduction to bioinformatics data
science and bioinformatics for
biomedical research you can attend all
of them just to kind of understand the
differences between the programs or if
you already know which one that you want
to participate in just give us another
day or two to finalize that process for
those of you that are from nepe there
will be a payment
um still that could either be covered by
you personally or by your institution
again those pis in your organization
you will be able to reach out to them
because this is a network uh based kind
of a program so so I'm sure that you
know they couldn't help you with that
so
um I don't know if there are any other
questions about the program topics
um kind of the outcomes the the schedule
or any of the registration questions
all right well if there are no questions
once again I'm happy to answer any
additional questions that you might have
um just generic questions about
um you know what we're doing
um or how to access a particular session
or topic and then Emmanuel could help
with
um other things as well
um says that she was not able to sign up
to the website with the LSU email
address but requested a course in the
form and used an LSU email address
are you from LSU
and which email address did you use
maybe you could paste it in the chat so
that we know
um which account that is
and thank you everyone
um if if you don't have any other
questions
um you're welcome to leave uh thank you
for joining today
okay uh
used a Cornell email address I'm
assuming that you're saying that you
signed up on the portal with your
Cornell address but you are actually at
LSU
yes okay perfect so
um Emmanuel do you have
um
in your form do you know
um
I don't think so
um so dude
I have him CC I have uh I have I have
him
okay perfect so
um yeah if your email address
um unfortunately
um if you could re-sign up with your LSU
email address
um that way you will be able to get the
um mlbrm account
foreign
all right great thank you does anyone
else have any other questions
yes I do have uh but it does seem like
our sequence and uh earlier that uh
I'm having trouble with registering with
uh this Red Cap so that means we
registered earlier so the so this time
we are not going to register again for
the Red Cap so the earlier application
will be noted as a present one
are How does it go I mean
in manual do you have Rajesh yadav
yeah I have I have him I have three
um
um I'm gonna put that on a
I I have um I have you you're uh you
wear a register for the introduction to
biafromatic yes yes that's correct yes
so is it uh however I don't have ashik I
don't find him
okay Asic will send his email ID
to you I said send your email ID
yeah he sent you already Maybe
yeah yeah but uh it's been a um I
haven't received his registration
so did you try already
did you travel to to register sorry
because I haven't
okay I will uh I will ask him to do if
not then he will he will he will email
you
perfect I have I have kipi's email on my
file so if I don't receive anything I
will contact it again to be sure that
he's registered yeah I will do it that's
it yeah thank you okay perfect and again
if you have any other questions about
registration for lbrn please um make
sure that you resolve that in the next
in a week or so uh with Emmanuel
um you have her email address there as
well
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining today
um we're gonna just uh wrap it up here
in the next few minutes so if you do
have any final questions I'm happy to
answer those
all right excellent well thank you so
much Emmanuel for joining us thank you
to you
thank you everyone and hope to see you
in the next few sessions